what's the Debbie thanks very much for
talking to us I don't want you to tell
me about your concerns for the deep
ocean floor and it's I suppose a little
bit overlooked in terms of our concerns
about the oceans isn't it the world has
become very anxious to get hold of rare
metals which shall now have been found
in crisis in Africa particularly which
we use in many of the modern electronic
apparatus particularly batteries and so
there has been a big search put on and
human beings being the sort of people
there are they they look everywhere and
someone says what about the deep seas
and stuff there and the certain
indications that there could be what we
are asking is that we should not go in
and trash an area of the globe about
which we know hardly anything until
we've done the proper research in short
we want a moratorium against action of
industrializing and mining the deep sea
you've got to recognize that actually
the deep sea is largely unexplored but
what we do know and what the research
that we have just publishing now
illustrates is that it is absolutely
crucial the deep sea in many ways which
we don't fully understand yet it there
are ecosystems there which are very
important for the health of the sea in
general and so we were faced with the
prospect of big industry going in and
churning up the but gotten the bottom of
the ocean what we do know and what this
report illustrates is that this produces
a great plume of mud and deposits which
can be scattered far from the depths of
the ocean into all parts of the ocean
which we couldn't be very very
destructive
zoomy there are still undiscovered
species down there 400 yes and and
although it might be interesting to
biota biologists that there should be
unknown species that is not the only
issue the issue is much more about the
whole health of the oceans we don't yet
know enough about the part
which the deep-sea plays in the health
of the oceans so this report says which
goes into the detail of the possible
consequences of this is whatever you do
please do the science before you go in
and destroy because that's what it
that's what it is mining is a polite
word it mining also means destruction
and destruction of an ecosystem of which
we know pathetically little on this
issue at the moment of of coronavirus
now I know you've talked in in the past
talked actually quite recently about
overpopulation the amount of people on
the planet sand the effect that is in
particular having or on other species
could this be another dimension of that
of people living cheek-by-jowl and then
the ability of viruses to pass through
quite easily like death when was that
14th century something not so many
people around the Black Death killed
thousands of people thousands of people
and the besides the world population or
indeed the population of this country or
Europe was tiny compared with what it is
now so if epidemics can go around the
world and have gone around the world in
the past I would like to say whoa whoa
it's all our fault because that's the
kind of fashionable thing to say that we
are overpopulated now but it just
doesn't be that argument doesn't hold
water there has been lots of other
epidemics of swine flu about five SARS
and so on and it goes right back into
the pestilence in the bank death so I
can't really say that what we're going
through now is a consequence of
overpopulation and your hopes for cop 26
in Glasgow of course in the United
Kingdom the global focus on our role in
this country on advancing the the battle
against climate change do you have high
hopes for that or is it could have just
turned out to be a nice walking shot I
have desperate hopes for that we've done
the talking the talking the really
productive piece of talking went on was
in Paris
years ago what everyone and what was
decided and then that and the whole
meeting agreed upon was what should be
done what cop coming up in Glasgow is
going to have to say is how where is the
money
who's going to do with it it's going to
deal with nuts and bolts with practical
politics we know where we've got to go
we know what the dangers are we know how
to fix them but now we've got to do it
and so the the sweet talk that is easy
enough to indulge in is not enough
anymore now it's a hard talk so it's
going to be hard and tough but it but it
carries the hopes of the world with it
so and we have a big responsibility over
we can influence the way it goes where
the hosts the trouble is things like
coronavirus and other things come along
that blow me off course but one hopes
that one keeps her eye on the ball when
it comes to this one you know you sound
an awful lot like greater tunberg there
i'm your generations with greatest
respect generations apart but I mean is
it her and her generation people like
her who are going to hold feet to the
fire to make sure this follow-through
from things like cop 26 you know the
world we're talking about belongs to
your people are at the moment young and
they don't have the vote they have no
way of expressing themselves and so you
can't cut out the part of the political
process but what young people can do is
to convince the politicians that they
mean it and the nest days they didn't
happening that they're given the support
they won't get the vote of the of the
young people when it comes so I I
welcome that the fact that young people
are explicit and clear about what they
want to happen and because it's
tomorrow's problem but they are too
but there is some criticism of a very
particular and her interpretation of the
pure science is it your view that yes of
course the science is fundamentally
important but but that passion is what
you actually need my my reading of
graduates on Berk is that she is very
respectful for the science and she says
in a modest way I am NOT a scientist I
have not studied the the upper
atmosphere the past 30 years but I know
people who have and I know what they say
and the rest of the world ought to take
notice that's all she's asking and
that's I think how you've always
conducted your career is it nicety yes
well I I mean I'm ignorant of the
science of the upper atmosphere I'm
don't pretend to be I meant might know
rather more about chimpanzees and
penguins
it's a David Attenborough great to see
you thank you very much thank you very
much